[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est la journée du fromage
je vous le dis c'est la tablette aura
réussi à faire arriver le fromage le
plus rapidement d'un côté à l'autre qui
aura le droit de réponse d'accord c'est
très fort
oui ça c'est la piscine ou fromage
l'équipe gagnante des signes aura à la
fin l'adversaire qui devra porter un
collier de fromage jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission allô coller de francs grâce
ici le col et fromagers non mais bon on
ne jette pas vraiment japon ne change
pas de combat je vous le dis je suis
très heureux d'être avec vous ce soit
puisque ce soit je vous le dis c'est
l'anniversaire de kelly
[Applaudissements]
alors à la halle à 28 ans kelly merci je
suis hyper content pour toi ça te fera
ça te fait plaisir
oui ça me fait très plaisir alors massa
28 ans mais comme le fait oui ça me fait
alors contre le fait je lis franchement
oui on a la paix le temps voilà je
voulais tous les terrains j'ai juste un
petit gâteau voilà tout ça j'ai pas que
j'ai pas grand chose je veux dire
vraiment la vérité on appelle d'entrée
pas un truc mais on va préparer un truc
très vite je fais un petit truc sobre
d'accord mais sur féret c'est
l'anniversaire de caddie c'est une
petite souris dans un petit gâteau c'est
rien du tout st gall ancienne
présentatrice de jt va jouer dans le
téléfilm meurtre à omaha beach à la
bonne réponse mélanie version de kenny
bel anniversaire qu'elle
[Applaudissements]
non
contre quoi florence qu'au fpi
[Applaudissements]
on est là çanakkale on y va contre le
vent tourne contre quoi florence foresti
at elle poussé un gros coup de gueule
allez on y va babbitt il faut le faire
quand même dépêché en éliminant les
mains sans les mains et agathe et kelly
le passage de relais alors florence
foresti pousse un coup de gueule contre
les kiosques à journaux qui diffuse des
magazines pornos mais non non c'est pas
tout à fait ça les îles les les aident à
nous à coups de gueule contre le
magazine porno dont on voit en kiosque
l'image en gros et est accessible du
cous enfin je pense que les couvertures
à la kia cup contre les couvertures de
magazines de charme hier sur son compte
instagram florence foresti a poussé un
coup de gueule contre les affiches
pornographiques qu'on peut voir sur les
kiosques parisiens
elle a déclaré est-ce qu'on est obligé
de se taper ça tous les jours sur nos
kiosques
pour mémoire les enfants des yeux et un
cerveau donc là ça la dérange et ça nuit
sur la plage c'est pareil pour l'âme et
roanne - tu veux dire est qu'elle est là
j'ai foiré
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans quelle émission at-on peignoir bleu
pâle la célèbre chanteuse américaine
anastasia les fesses à l'air d'aller
anastasia c'est ça normalement vous
devriez le mec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on fait la fête le ciel aux noces
avec les stars italiennes exactement
dans cette catégorie
[Applaudissements]